gut für Körper Geist und Seele aber auch
kulinarisch wirklich ein top-erlebnis
denn man kann ja daraus lavendeltee
machen man kann Lavendel zum Würzen
verwenden man kann lavendelsirup
Lavendel Honig alles mögliche herstellen
man kann sie auch in Säckchen machen und
zwischen die kleiderlegenden das ist ein
ganz ganz natürlicher Duftstoff da
braucht ihr auch kein Weichspüler mehr
der einen guten Duft hat und es reicht
wirklich aus und es ist gut gegen Motten
das ist ganz ganz wichtig das hält auch
Ungeziefer genau denn für uns Menschen
ist der Lavendel Duft wirklich sehr
schön und sehr wohl und für Insekten
aller Art ist Lavendel Duft nämlich gar
nicht schön das heißt Insekten bleiben
einfach gut